precast concrete walls have a tough
exterior that holds up to all kinds of
weather but making these structural wall
panels is an inside job production
starts with a mix of crushed rock and
sand this collection is limestone based
the mineral mix can be altered for
different strengths and finishes a
conveyor delivers the collection of
minerals to a huge mixer beaters whip
the ingredients into a thick gritty mix
before they cast the wall a crew
arranges giant foam letters to make an
imprint in the mold a release agent is
sprayed onto the casting form and
letters high-strength steel cables are
strung throughout the form with a
hydraulic device they pull each cable to
a specific tension
then they bend a rebar rod into a loop
the rebar loops are linked creating long
cages they place one cage at the top of
the forum and one at the bottom then the
team inserts a sheet of welded wire mesh
it's been cut to fit the size of the
forum they're now ready to pour concrete
a truck dispenses the concrete directly
into the forum the concrete flows around
the steel reinforcement the steel will
keep the walls strong when the concrete
expands and contracts as the weather
changes the team spreads the concrete
and levels it with a tool called a
screed this first layer of the wall
panel is essentially one side of a
sandwich it will be the exterior part of
the wall at the center of the sandwich
is this rigid foam insulation it studied
with protrusions to secure to the
concrete more steel reinforced concrete
completes the wall sandwich
after about 12 hours the wall is solid
enough to be handled they take it
outdoors where a workers sandblast a
small section of the exterior side this
removes the surface cement to expose the
aggregate creating a decorative band
next to the embossed lettering after a
three day cure the precast concrete wall
is ready for the construction site the
concrete continues to cure over time so
these precast walls will stand strong
for many years